welcome back to cloud storage bytes so
far we've talked a lot about how to use
Google Cloud storage for managing data
to optimizing performance but there's
one important topic that we haven't
discussed yet the price tag have you
ever gone grocery shopping while you're
hungry and you ended up blowing your
budget right out of the water I find
that a list can be really helpful for me
here so that I don't overestimate my
snack quirements this kind of planning
can be helpful with cloud storage too
just like when grocery shopping it's a
good idea to predict and track your data
usage so you can anticipate your monthly
costs since cloud storage billing is a
little bit more complicated than grocery
shopping we'll need to take a closer
look
pricing is a compilation of several
different components data storage
networking operations and retrieval and
early deletion fees each of these
components has its own pricing tables
that show cost based on factors such as
region and operation type this means
that each company's total cost is going
to be completely different and based
upon specific requirements so as much as
I'd like to tell you exactly what your
bottom line is going to be I can't
instead I can give an overview of each
pricing category using my company Jen's
jams suppose I have the following
storage usage pattern in a given month
let's find out how much my company will
pay the first two lines here are in the
data storage category data storage costs
apply to your at rest storage of your
data in cloud storage for a quick
refresher at rest means that the data is
physically on the disk itself and not
somewhere else in transit through the
network or only temporarily housed there
regional or multi regional storage is
appropriate for storing data that's
frequently accessed such as surfing
website content interactive workloads or
data supporting mobile and gaming
applications for Jen's jams we've picked
multi-regional storage because we've got
customers all over the world
my company's cost for multi region
storage is 2.6 cents per
a bite so the total cost for
multi-regional storage this month is
going to be one thousand five hundred
ninety seven dollars and forty four
cents the majority of my company's music
is held in the multi-regional storage so
that each song can be as accessible as
possible
the next expense is also for data
storage but this is for a Nearline
storage Nearline storage as you'd
remember is a low-cost highly durable
storage service for storing in
frequently accessed data it's a better
choice than multi-regional storage or
regional storage in scenarios were
slightly lower availability 30-day
minimum storage duration and cost for
data access are acceptable trade-offs
for lower storage costs Nearline storage
is ideal for infrequently read or
modified data we're talking once a month
or less and Nearline storage is also
appropriate for data backup disaster
recovery and archival storage at gents
jams we use Nearline storage to backup
our music collection in the event that a
song gets lost I also use Nearline
storage for songs that are rarely ever
downloaded Nearline storage for the u.s.
multi-region location is one cent per
gigabyte so the total cost here is 1,024
dollars notice that this is less than
the total cost of multi-regional storage
even though i'm storing more data next
up in my pricing table is network costs
network usage charges apply when an
object or object metadata is read from
your buckets that is egress the cost
depends on several factors and includes
caveats for example like circumstances
with the network egress within GCP for
example data egress from your bucket to
an on cloud storage Google cloud
platform service is free if your bucket
is located in a region the GCP service
is located in a multi region and both
locations are on the same continent so
accessing data in a u.s. East one bucket
with a US App Engine instance would be
free
my company's egress falls under general
network usage so none of those special
use cases apply network ingress is free
an operation is an
action that makes changes to or
retrieves information about buckets and
objects in cloud storage operations are
divided into three different categories
Class A Class B and free there's a lot
to each of these categories so for
details go ahead and check the link
documentation cost for operations vary
by operation class and storage class in
my case
Class A operations are in multi region
storage so the cost is five cents per
10,000 operations there are Class B
operations and multi-regional storage
data and Nearline storage data and those
are priced differently my totals are $4
and $1 respectively
because Nearline storage and cold line
storage are intended for storing in
frequently accessed data there are
additional costs associated with
retrieval and minimum storage durations
but again more about that in the
documentation and there you have it my
company's cloud storage usage comes out
to a total of seven thousand four
hundred sixty dollars and 22 cents
there's quite a bit more to billing than
what I've shown you today and prices may
change after this video is released so
please be sure to check out the
documentation linked below for the most
up-to-date pricing information there's
plenty more to discuss about billing but
that's a totally different episode don't
forget to subscribe give us a like and
tell us what you want to learn about
Google Cloud storage thanks for joining
us on this quick fight of cloud storage
see you next time
[Music]